we bring the drama naturally we don't
have to try Andy is back yes for Season
eleven season 11 to me this season it's
gonna be totally different it's not the
mean girl drama you know there's a lot
of personal issues that are going on
this season that people are dealing with
life-changing things so it's real-life
drama instead of this kind of petty
back-and-forth don't get me wrong you
know it is the housewives gonna say we
got to deliver what the people are
tuning in for both sides yeah you're
definitely gonna get both sides to say
what when the trailer did drop some fans
like well what's happening this season I
thought it was a little interesting too
because it was certain things I was like
underwater and put that in there cuz I
know it was a lot more juicy things that
happened that I felt like mm okay well
maybe they didn't want to give it all to
you in a trailer and when I tell you a
lot of things happen even after they
released the trailer it's been a lot to
happen in just the last two weeks
okay so you guys were delivering up
until the last minute we were when I
tell you my and my last day of taping
for this season was Saturday night okay
Wow people were crying okay not me this
time though what let's wait elebrate
that well okay I'm in it I did have a
couple tears this evening I'm not gonna
lie to you but not on that final day of
camping exactly I had this little
ongoing joke I don't want to give away
who it is but I said wow you are
definitely the candy this year you know
people like why are you always crying I
did have a moment of tears but not that
much there's someone who
you know does it really do that that
it's having okay you pass the box of
tissues not the torch right here you go
nowhere my friend dated him
they still communicate he's a dog
Porsche how would you explain the
dynamic between the two of you what
we're gonna see this season well um I
would say it's a rollercoaster between
she and I I was cool with us starting on
a better note but I think the issue was
in her new relationship I knew things
about her significant other and when the
season first started in my mind I was
trying to figure out do I have these
conversations with her with the group
because you know we all discussed
everybody's new men on the showed new
man whatever basically you know there
was but there was some tea dropping okay
locked away and find out what that T is
the way apart for me it was a more of a
thing of you know if this is a new
relationship you know you should know
what what is what you're getting into
what you're getting into but I think
more so after finding out that you know
they wouldn't want to have a family
together at that point man I was just
kind of like you know what does it even
matter anymore for me to share this
there's a baby boom in Atlanta there is
Porsha is expecting Kenya who's not a
cast member this year I also expected
are we gonna get to see any of Kenya's
journey on the show this year who does
she pop up at all
well she does pop up okay she does pop
up once to my begging of course so I
kind of twisted their arms she is gonna
be there it's just you know everything
happens for a reason this was a time
that she needed to focus on her baby
yeah you know to me and being healthy
but do I feel like she should be back or
that she would be back and then Marlo's
back in like a bigger capacity I guess
that we've seen her before
how do you feel about that actually I
like it
she's she's funny yes she's definitely
the person who loves to call people out
she's doing it a lot this year
and she's definitely bringing the fash
of him okay
she's bringing the fashion and maybe
picking up some of the bone collecting
that sure a left off but oh for sure for
sure
[Music]
[Applause]